The same brainstorming sessions there are no bad ideas. Fair enough,
but at some point you have to call out the ones
that some counterproductive or incoherent. The first idea here is in
that category since it makes no sense at all. The input to
a fragment shader is the point inside a triangle, typically produced
by triangle set up. The application doesn't feed service points the
GPU. It provides triangles. Even if it fed such points the
GPU, these points would not normally be properly placed on the screen.
That's something the vertex shader does. Transforms the triangle to screen
coordinates, so forget idea number one. The second idea is a
good one, if we know early on that the fragment is
visible, then we don't have to use the fragment shader at all.
GPUs take advantage of this and so perform the Z-depth test
early. So, saving not executing that fragment shader's program. This type
of speed up is called Early-Z, after the fragment is computed,
its then put into the Z buffer and color image as usual.
However, there's a little subtle catch with this idea, if
the fragment shader, itself, actually changes the Z-depth value passed
in. Then you can not safely check this Z-depth before
running the shader program. That said, about 99.44 of all
fragment shaders never touch the Z-depth. In fact, in web
GL it's not currently possible. Though this has been proposed
as an extension. This third idea of making each core
be usable as either a vertex a fragment shader is worthwhile.
This in fact ia how modern GP is architected. Vertex and
fragment shaders are close enough together and functionality that a single core
can be used as either. This is called a unified shader.
An advantage for the fragment shader bottleneck problem is that such course
to be allocated on-the-fly. If fragments of piling up, cores are
assigned to them. If vertices are queued up, cores are moved to
this area. The first solution doesn't change anything as far as the
fragment shader goes. The same number of pixels will be covered and
generate fragments so that the fragment shader still has
to work as hard. Where's the end, adding more triangles
means more strain on other parts of the pipeline, such
as the vertex shader. So, this idea causes more overall
[UNKNOWN],
not less.